[Music]
thanks Dylan for the
intro and you also might notice that I'm
just here alone unfortunately my
colleague Alona is out sick so um I
guess it's just going to be me so when
we prepare this talk we were like saying
hey we working with time serus and it's
cool to like show things that work out
but both of us have spent the past 20
years working on this and we wanted to
share a couple of the failures we've
seen on the way because I thought it
might be interesting also for you if
you're working with time
serious um about that so first of all
what are time serious and I can just ask
you in the room like who of you has
worked with time serus Data
before cool how many of you have been to
a pi data conference that had a Time
serious
talk exactly
and and and that's that's seriously
that's a problem and so what is time
serious data I'm just making sure that
everybody in room gets it in the end
we're talking about records of time and
a key or name of a variable and the
value that is recorded over the course
of time you can see that there in this
aary example and in the slightly more
real example and um they're nothing new
they have been around or let's say used
by Engineers around the world for many
many years in industrial Control Systems
scatter systems some of you might have
heard this term they are all around you
and sometimes you don't even realize it
and so where they are commonly found
couple of examples financial data is
probably the one uh that you know the
best e system so enterprise resource
planning markets wherever big money is
involved it's interesting what happened
in the past and most importantly what
will happen in the future because this
is where the money is second part is um
you see this little ACG recording it's
about healthc care it's about consumer
iot you probably all have an Apple Watch
they're doing time serious analytics all
the time on the Fly
um there's also weather data forecasting
of the weather what will happen tomorrow
these are all Dynamic time time series
models that are happening there the last
part is an example you've probably all
used a grafana dashboard to get insights
about what's happening in your systems
all of that is time serious data but to
generalize that it's an industrial
internet of things it's in automation
it's in sensors it's in robotics so it's
almost everywhere the thing is what's so
special about it you've said like you
have been to Pi data events but there
were no time serious talk where's nobody
talking about it is it easy I don't I
personally don't think so time data is
special in a way that it has a very high
cardinality so it's typically very very
long serious because if you record
something over a long time then there's
a lot of variables in there the second
part is as you're talking about real
systems there's a lot of noise in there
so it's often noisy so you have noise
problems in there and um when you look
at these systems it's rarely that one
single sensor comes alone they usually
come in groups or of 10,000 50,000 or
100 ,000 so it's easily also a problem
to deal with massive
parallelity the other thing is even if
you have a lot of data it doesn't mean
that there's a ton of information in it
if a recording that you take every
milliseconds of the exact same value
great you use up a lot of memory but the
amount of information you're getting is
not so much you could compress it to say
the value is one and it goes on for the
next 6 hours that has about the same
level of information of recording it
every millisecond but that means be very
careful about the information you're
getting out of uh such systems when
you're saying oh yeah we have 20 gab of
data of that machine does it really tell
us anything if it runs stable as a flat
line often many serious and parallel
I've just said the uh the thing machine
just imagine you run a lot of machines
in parallel if you go to let's say a
Refinery you can easily have 100,000
500,000 sensors that are recorded and if
you want to do time serious analytics
and that it's a whole different question
when you're saying you just just looking
at One sensor the other thing is
typically times Serv data have the
property that they come in all the time
record it at a certain frequency at a
certain amount and here's the thing it
doesn't stop it's not that you scan a
book and you're done with scanning that
book you can do your analytics run a
model and forecasting it or so on time
serers have the the points that they
continue meaning if you take a database
stump you analyze that you run a model
it's very like that you'll miss the very
recent history the thing is as we' seen
this data is almost everywhere it means
uh the answers are often highly time
critical and also it can mean that the
monetary impact of working with that
data can be quite huge and so what's so
what's so special about it yeah it has a
time stamp so guess yeah you're time
serious analyst but um let's get a
little bit more serious like why do
companies care about time serious data
it's basically a part about datadriven
analytics when you run want to run your
company better typically about factors
that are business value driven like you
want to be faster better cheaper or in
some cases happily they want to be more
sustainable but it's also the external
factors that uh with uncertainty meaning
volatility in the markets in Supply
chains and so on the complexity and the
ambiguity of events that are happening
around you time serious analytics become
ever more important also competitive
pressure mean you need to get better in
what you're currently doing so time Ser
analytics is yet the next thing business
forecasting and so on but there's also
points like compliance and safety and
experience experience loss in the job
market so let me give you a general
overview and that is nothing that is
python specific but uh it has more to do
with like the tasks that we're doing and
putting them in perspective just say
over time you record a certain kpi and
you have knowledge until right now very
simple you can draw this line and what
we often do is we write a report so we
aggregate the data until this point run
some descriptive statistics add up some
numbers and so on often people use
pandas to do that and that's fairly easy
producing this moving average that is
drawn there in yellow little bit more
complicated but still a fairly trivial
task to do where it becomes interesting
is whenever you want to look into the
future you want to forecast how this
series will uh will let's say proceed in
the coming future this is when you need
a model of somewhere or the other and
this is also one of the reasons why
we're here in this room because this is
in the end what a lot of us do when they
work with time serious data if we work
at Financial markets you want to
forecast what will happen next because
there's money in it if you run a machine
you want to know how a certain sensor or
the machine will do this is also where
the money is in but where the real money
is in is when you ask the inverse
question you're trying to optimize you
want to bring that certain kpi to a
certain goal and you want to know what
you have to do right now in order to
reach this goal optimization is where
the real fun in Time series is and like
when you ask our friends in uh
mechanical engineering and so on this is
where they spend most of their time
solving optimization problems in
Direction the last part I will also not
miss out it's about detecting certain
patterns certain events in there over
time for the examples today I used a
very simple tool to generate time series
data it's my temperature sensor at home
this is not a picture of the actual
sensor but build one yourself it's a
great way of testing out data pipelines
and showing how you can uh miraculously
fail at the easiest things dealing with
time series data so I highly encourage
you to do that but now let's come into
the topic of today that is talking about
the fail and I want the fails and the
first thing that I recurrently see when
I coach teams at time serious projects
is dealing with that time serious data
we completely
forget what is the context of the data
we're talking about we treat it like
regular tabular data a database stum
something we get out of our postgress we
download the variables and we don't talk
about context what do I mean with that
let's start pretty simple this one here
is in this case not my uh temperature on
in the garden this is my oven at home
where I bake uh pizza and um I'd like
you to have a guess what is the real
signal between these readings that are
taken approximately UH 60 seconds apart
anyone have an idea because it's noisy
data pretty good you saw it it was
probably a too easy example because this
is the data noise filtered in that case
pretty simple why am I trying to show
you that just imagine and it's about
sampling and the frequency that you have
behind just imagine you would just
sample here here here here here and here
and you try to interpolate this line you
could get wrongly the impression that
it's
flat why do I tell you that whenever you
work with time series data make sure
that the sampling frequency you look at
the data in is actually matching the
real process that is below it this is
the most common failure I've seen
working with people time series data
that don't think about the sampling
frequency but let's turn this around
every single sensor that we're dealing
with comes with their own noise in this
case I've just taken um my partic
particular meta sensor 10 mic uh 10
micrometers and just taking that data
but that be pretty clear what I put in
there is the arrow bar that comes from
the sensor itself according to the data
sheet from the manufacturer another
thing that I highly encourage you to is
when you take these uh take time serious
data think about where does the error
come from for that signal that you're
looking about because no matter how you
look at this data when you resample it
which is what I see a lot of people
doing when they deal with time series
data you might let's say fool yourself
I've shown you here two possible ways of
taking this discrete measurements taken
at the at the given sample frequency how
you could like connect them just a
straight line from point to point very
very noisy everybody will say hey no
model will be will be working with that
you could also just say we resample the
frequency as it is to instead of every
about 90 seconds to every 30 minutes and
flatten by that way but you can
immediately see that there's a couple of
drawbacks with that so this line here
this resampling line will Trail the
actual
measurements why is that important if
you take that resampled data and train a
model with it you will fool yourself
because you're off by a certain time
frame because you created an artifact
and removed information about that so
thinking about how you can do it right
when you are resampling your data I
strongly encourage you to think about
what's the error behind and you see in
this case here it's the red line there
that uses the same 30 minute uh
intervals to resample but the only
difference is I don't take
every value that is in that 30 minute
box and take an average about and put
Place one dot at a certain arbitary
point in time but I use an unsymmetrical
window in this case that matches the
error distribution of the underlying
signal because I said to you before
particular mattera the error is uh
distributed gaan and because of that the
right window function can make a huge
difference when you interpret that line
so when you ignore all of that you're
removing really really valuable
information from the signal that you're
treating with and so taking the signal
out of context is something where I say
hey please don't do that you make your
life subsequently significantly
harder that being said we're dealing
with real data so often that means you
can have massive outliers in that case
but the thing is finding algorithms how
to find out what's true and what is not
is not so easy there's we could spend
probably an hour or two talking about
different techniques how to do that but
I'm just saying to Mark something like
this talk to our friends in signals
processing in electrical engineering
they are the experts about that it's not
us data scientists need to find that out
there's a lot of beautiful libraries to
do this please do not reinvent the wheel
read in this case sorry to say the
manual how to do it right and please
don't don't just down sample the
data second part ignoring the history
seen a lot of people in projects when
they're starting off uh with time
serious data to just say hey we treat it
as tabular data there's an entry at a
certain point in time and I can do my
calculations exactly the way as I should
do but to remind you of the picture I
had in the beginning if we want to look
into the future we are taking
assumptions if we think about it or not
if we if we're saying we don't do
anything we take an implicit assumption
that everything stays the same that the
system that we're talking about is the
uh is exactly the same as it was before
which is really the reality the one
thing we can be sure about is that the
further we look into the future taking
the simplicit assumptions the less
likely it is that everything stays the
same why am I saying that because what
typical thing what people do um when
they look into the future they try to do
auto regressive analysis what does Auto
regressive analysis mean it's just you
look at the data as you have it just
with a time stamp and you don't take any
external information so additional
sensors or so on into it in this case
you take an implicit assumption that the
signal you are seeing is composed of a
trend of a seasonal component and some
residual so that's taken together as a
in this case multiplicative uh um
operation is going uh like that keep
that in mind because I'll come back to
this problem and this assumption later
on with another of my
failures training models brings me to a
really really good point I've seen or
reviewed so many projects where people
take the test data or the totally
available data and just do a regular
train test split 8020 is I think what
most people do these days and a typical
kall kall cross
validation looks like this if you take
the SK learn model selection uh
splitting tool please don't do that when
you work with with time series please do
not the reason is history matters and
you should do incremental time series
splits cuz otherwise what you do if you
do this is you have a information
bleeding because you want to forecast
but you get train this model on
something that it already knows about in
the future this is really not great
please don't do it a lot of garbage will
come out and the models will even be
less good than they already
are third one using just a simple
standard kpi to evaluate the performance
of your
models what do I mean with that when you
work with regression uh regression tools
and you try to go in the future mean
absolute error root mean square error
these are the typical things how you say
hey I have a goodness of fit and so on
of course there's more advanced measures
but these are just two abary
examples when you talk about time serus
there are specialized measures that you
need to take care of because even if
your model is just 1% off for every
forecast that you
have it really matters if you're if
you're having the direction of that
error right or wrong because let's just
say you're in financial markets you're
always uh 1% off but you're always
predicting the wrong direction it's a
great way to very effectively lose a lot
of money we don't want to do that so
please use specialized kpis and take
them in
perspective to make sure that you answer
the business questions you having
correctly these are not typically the
measures you're seeing in a lot of
regressional analysis but please take
that step back and ask yourself if
you're asking uh if you're asking the
right question the answer is it's
complicated it depends what I'm seeing
in many of the projects I'm in it's not
any of those alone that you take it's
the comparative uh the comparative
combination of all of those to say if
it's a good model or not and the choice
of model itself it always of course
depends there's a big difference in
terms of models that are great into a
very short time frame or a very long
time frame that's one thing but it's not
just about the time frame that you're
looking at it's also what is the
Dynamics that this model can show are
they able to just give you one point
every half an hour or can they capture
the entire dynamics of the system if
you're working with heavily down sampled
data it's very unlikely that your model
will be able to capture the whole
Dynamics so please be aware of that when
you have a complex uh data preparation
pipeline that does complex filtering you
might be applying very well a low pass
filter where you remove all the
information about the Dynamics whereas
the question that your business is
trying to answer is actually a highly
Dynamic one so the Precision required I
often see teams continuing to work and
to work to work to get all these kpis
better uh to make them better and better
ask the question what's good
enough sometimes it's just enough what
you have right now and move on to a
different problem the next point is
robots n
is your model and the model
structure able to perform well under
different conditions we'll come to that
in a second and the last part is the
assumptions and knowledge of the system
if you're going in and saying hey I just
have the data I know nothing about the
system I'm talking about it's typically
a lot harder to work with time serus
data than when you have a deep
understanding of the system that is
behind it and just a little beam to that
that's exactly the point you've been
probably when working in Industry being
asked to I give a forecast for the next
couple of years that's exactly the point
the assumptions really
matter I've given you here a couple of
popular examples for different model
categories that have uh that have like
seen occurring very very frequently over
the past couple of years simple and
classic models like the seasonal
decomposition or statistical models like
ARA and arimax put them in two different
uh two different uh columns for the
reason you can have models that stand
for uh for themselves meing that just
take the variable in question or ones
that use exogeneous information so
additional information as well in order
to go forward there are ones like ARX or
more complex the Bazooka lstms or RNN
with caras that are used frequently and
why am I saying that the one that I'm
often seeing performing the very
best for most of the business questions
I'm seeing is in the end linear
regression that is smartly chosen on
rightly pre-filtered data for questions
that you're asking give you the example
of um of predictive maintenance just
taking I don't know the last week of a
certain machine taking a performance of
a certain predictor just doing a linear
Focus really cheap to run it really
cheap to train it and the Precision is
often better than some of these bazooka
models that you see out there so ask
yourself very wisely if it's worth to go
down the super complicated route and
make sure that uh and basically go into
a position where you easily can go into
let's say a hallucination situation
because in the end whenever you look in
the future you're extrapolating
make it can be it can be a mixed model
as well it can be also a very very
simple linear regression on that very
very function itself but we can discuss
that afterwards in detail fail number
four and I need to look into time
politely ignoring cross dependencies I
said previously that uh the variables
we're talking about are really coming
alone and I give you here an example
spirous correlation the amounts in US of
spending on science space and technology
and the suicides by hanging of course
you can make up a story how this is
correlated in some way but why am i
showing this example a lot of the cases
you think that observations you have in
a certain system may not be correlated
at all often with time series especially
you have uh very limited knowledge
you're trying to describe a system
meaning a black box you have only a
certain number of inputs that you know
and there may be very Mel more other
inputs that you don't
know what does that mean it means you
need to take assumption what happens to
those or do surgard modeling for these
inputs in order to understand how these
outputs out of which you also may not
know some some of those and you also
don't know which of them are feedback to
the original inputs and so that being
said the cause and effect in such
systems is something you cannot ignore
and if you go forward here's an example
from an output and an input uh in a
certain variable in this case visually
You' probably say yeah I see this peak
up there and I see a peak down there and
it's slightly time shifted great input
and output but it points to another
problem that often things don't happen
at the same time and if you just go back
to this regular pandas data frame where
you're saying hey I just have a
multiplication of this column and that
column and you have a time frame hey
we're talking about something different
so that being said if you want to dive
into this topic which which is in the
end a rabbit hole talk to our friends
and Signal processing once again because
there's beautiful Solutions out there
for all of these problems and these
problems have been solved many many
years ago so in that case it's a fail if
you don't look and reuse this uh these
materials let me give you an example
what it means when uh when I say with
calculating stuff here's an very simple
example where this I don't think this
works uh where this kpi is just
calculated and I try to like highlight
this here U by 1 hour if you just do it
columna you come out to this kpi to 101%
doesn't make much sense the actual
calculation looks like this but there's
a second problem with that what you can
also see from this is not all of these
variables are sampled at the same
frequency because you have only discrete
readings as we established in the very
beginning so again be very aware of the
assumptions you take when you do such
calculations do we do interpolation do
you do forward filling do you do down
sampling what is the right choice for
the system
being aware of the assumptions you
implicitly put in into such operation
can make a huge impact on the the output
that you produce by these models and the
next point is coming back to
cardinality just IM like if you just
sample every minute that variable for
one year you get up about a little bit
more than half a million lines not so
not a problem can fit in pretty much
every memory no databases will will have
any problem with that but just imagine
you have 5,000 of these columns it's
pretty it's probably a pretty bad idea
to store them in a in a regular columnar
database that's the reason why other
systems exists to deal with that
cardinality to store them differently
but what does it mean for us here as uh
python
users one data frame for the whole
system where you have your 5,000
variables in is also a pretty bad idea
narrow down your data sets to what you
actually need and be aware of the memory
you're using not only your CTO will be
happy about less of the cloud spending
you'll have on your clusters but you
also also don't have to wait 6 hours
before some of the calculations complete
and you will not use spark be aware of
the impact that it has um what type of
variables you're using when you're
dealing with in this case I don't want
to use the word big data but with large
data sets in that way thinking first
about what you're trying to control uh
to calculate can actually make a huge
difference fail number five assuming
that models are static and you can just
deploy you remember this this example
had with the seasonal
decomposition just imagine we're doing
that in the beginning here but something
has truly changed so our forecast shows
that the beer consumption in Australia
will straight go up it totally didn't
because if we just trained our model
here at that snapshot took a database
download you probably agree that's not a
great idea what does it mean for us uh
in that
way time series models one thing is true
like if you train a model you definitely
will have to retrain it continuously all
the time and it has massive impact on
the infrastructure you're putting into
play please don't try uh try to um te uh
to train your time series models offline
in a Jupiter notebook build automation
infrastructure how you can automatically
deploy a new model structure find an a
way how you can robustly train your
hyperparameters for the model structure
and most importantly in a very time
efficient and computationally efficient
way of how to train your parameters
based on the new that data comes in and
I can only repeat that one does not
simply train one time series model you
have to do it over and over again and
why does it matter here's an example
from uh from one of the projects I've
worked previously on I've worked for not
the company that has depicted here that
was just the example pckage that came up
uh in the Creative Commons but like
airplanes they have turbines maybe two
maybe four turbines work very much the
same in that way but they all come with
slightly different initial conditions
they have a different maintenance
history different age and so on um they
have different boundary conditions they
operated differently but the model
structure themselves and how they break
it's pretty much the same with all the
turbines out
there what is our answer if we want to
automatically train 10,000 models
retrain 10,000 models once a day monitor
the operation on those that's not an
easy question I've worked with that
customer uh and in the end there's an
operational team of four people that run
the entire operations behind that means
you need a massive scale of operation
but what it also means is you need a
super robust data pipeline that
addresses the um the cleaning of the
data that monitors data drift model
drift and all that stuff
automatically these are the problems
that are interesting and where let's say
taking all these points from these fails
together has a massive impact on the
success or not success I have a bonus
fail for
you time is almost up but it's enough
for the bonus fail and my my bonus fail
is assuming that time is
linear sounds funny but the reality it
is not just think about just a couple of
weeks ago we had a time change from
summertime to winter time which means if
you lose local time
stamps yeah you had the time of 2:00 in
the morning twice which May matter for
some things which may not matter for
other things but that's that's only one
thing of the weird things that can go
wrong with
time I don't know who of you have heard
of leap seconds every now and then leap
seconds are introduced and suddenly you
have an hour that has
3,601
seconds meaning if you now step by 1
hour you suddenly have an offset pretty
not cool the next thing that is also
pretty not cool is it's not just about
the absolute time stamps about it's
about also so time
Deltas or time spans that exactly
produce these problems even a leap year
can make a difference if you say oh yeah
every 30 days or every month we do
something the next thing is we are all
python developers here the one thing
that is absolutely not consistent
through all the machine learning
libraries is how timestamps are handled
between different libraries and so on so
that's that's a pretty big deal and the
next thing is even if you know that your
like local that your local time is there
and you know the machine stands in a
certain town be aware even the
assumption that where machine stands
will not change its time uh time zone is
a pretty bad one there's multiple
examples of towns that change time zones
I've had that happen and it was not a
great thing to happen don't assume
anything when you're working with time
stamps but my best practices I can share
with you are very simple convert any
time St you're getting at the time of
ingestion in your data pipeline into UTC
please do it don't work with time stamps
it like you'll do so many conversions
into SK learn SK time and whatsoever or
whatever other Library please just
convert at UTC at inest and the second
part is if you even want to be more sure
that it works just convert to Unix time
that's a pretty good choice if you're
like not working with Data before
1970 but and the last part the last part
is localization to your local time do it
at the end I could say in a in a in a
proval way hey let's make it someone
else's problem meaning a front- end
problem but in some cases it's the same
problem all over
again and with that my take- home
messages time series are a very special
type of regression problem
pre-processing the data can easily
obstruct your whole analysis and change
the entire outcome of why you were doing
this project entirely not because you
did a bad job in like training your
model and validating it but You' in in
the end you failed at the verification
meaning that you built the model right
in that way great forecasting models
often um involve domain expertise you
can make things significantly better
often if you have knowledge about how
the noise is distribute what the sensors
mean and so on which in some cases might
not may not be possible but why there
right first principles sometimes
Knowledge from engineering or physics
can really help you to make it easier
storage and retrieval of the large data
Amounts is often
underestimated we can have a different
talk about that and uh what happened
before also matters time serious and if
that's the one message you can really
take home is don't just train a model
once a time series model is not static
you will re need to do it again and uh
the last part it's not always DNS when
working with like regression must on
time zones it's always time zones and
with that thank you very much visit us
at the booth
and
all right thank you so much I think this
was a talk that I wish I had had earlier
in my career so I didn't have to learn
some of these uh the hard way um is
there any questions for
Sebastian um could you maybe say
something about quantifying uncertainty
espe
for can you repeat the question for that
so the question was basically about a
quantifying uncertainty and I think that
is that more referring to the sensors
themselves or more to like the uh to
like the forecasting uncertainty because
both of them are problems of its own
yeah most forecas okay in order to
forecast uh the let's say achievable
accuracy in a forecasting model I would
highly recommend to first look into um
understanding the uncertainty that comes
from them sensus itself if you have a 5%
uncertainty in the measurement that
initially goes in it is extremely
unlikely that you will be ever be able
to produce a model that is better than
this 5% it sounds so simple but please
don't forget that and so for forecasting
accuracy what does that mean if you're
Now using multiple sensors of their own
and they all have a 5% accuracy it's not
necess that these uh that these these
errors are additive there's the gaussian
error distribution with that so that's
the first step to get an idea about the
overall envelope how kind how good can
you get that's the first part about
forecasting accuracy the second part is
by the model itself depending on which
assumptions you take in cleaning the
data and um and or filtering the data it
can either get better in terms of a
achievable accuracy or worse because
depending on the time frame you're
looking at the Dynamics you're looking
at it again can also get get better the
one thing is always true you will not be
able to get better than the gaan error
distribution that's just information
theory in this very end I hope that it
like but we can continue this discussion
in detail if you want
yep thanks for the talk and tips uh I I
want to know do you have any suggestion
when we want to uh do data
normalizations when we are working with
sequence data because I think that it's
not like a
classic data that's not sequence that we
for instance we do minmax sometimes when
we want to turn a model like we find the
Max and mean and then bring everything
between zero and one but how is the
things working when we are working with
sequence data in mathematically you
could say you do a uh you do a work in a
different um in the end space because
you like do a space transformation in
that way that being said working with
just the information where certain
Maxima if I understood correctly Maxima
and Minima are I've seen working models
like that working very very well the
other thing that you can what I've seen
people doing with the Minima and Maxima
problems is with with working so-called
relative models which you basically
saying no matter where I'm starting my
forecast I start at zero because that's
numerically very like a lot simpler and
you're just saying hey I see a trend
upwards and downwards and then I do this
back transformation into where the
original value was and use that in order
to forecast the next value if that makes
sense but that goes with the same idea
Minima and Maxima to say hey we we're
trying to do it in a different space
Also what what may be useful in this
Minima and Maxima point is if they occur
in a certain
frequency think about if you can do your
forecasting in Fier space which is also
often a very great way of simplifying
your
problem any other
questions okay well let's thank our
speaker again thank you Sebastian thank
you very
[Music]
much